those who have studied the various
anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation know that this world has
quite a lot to fear enormous World
devouring monsters that thrive on an
endless stream of hate seemingly
innocuous statues waiting to snap your
neck the second you turn your back and a
shark-eyed old man with the power to
reach through solid concrete grab hold
of you with his rotting hands and drag
you into his own personal hell
scp-106 can pop into our world whenever
he wants but like many of the most
efficient Predators he has his own
designated Lair a pocket Dimension where
he can pull his prey and trap them in a
horrifying game of cat and mouse that
only ever ends one way in a painful
prolonged end we all know what scp-106
uses is pocket dimension for but what if
some of the other anomalies at the
foundation had a pocket dimension of
their very own a tiny parallel reality
that they could shape in their image and
use it for whatever they wanted what
might that look like a special team of
SCP Foundation operatives were tasked
with conducting an experiment using an
elaborate computer system to run
simulations and see what different
anomalies might do with their pocket
Dimensions should the opportunity ever
arise stranger things have certainly
happened at the SCP Foundation so they
prepared a list of anomalies that
presented the most potential for
interesting findings and fired up the
simulation for the very first subject
they selected an anomaly who was also a
colleague Dr bright and
scp-963 the monitor attached to the
computer running the simulation showed a
curious surprising picture there was a
door with one sign bright council
meeting inside past the door was a long
conference table packed to the brim with
different attendees the regards d-class
scientists men and women all wearing the
trademark anomalous amulet it was every
single incarnation of the doctor himself
all talking over each other with great
enthusiasm at the head of the table
there was a monitor depicting the
current incarnation of Dr bright going
about his daily life on a live video
feed all of the many many Dr brytes were
instructing him giving him advice and
guidance on every impulse and decision
some Dr brights were brandishing pies
others chainsaws and others were drawing
schematics for laser guns and catapults
the Council of brights was working
together devising pranks schemes and
general Tom Foolery the research team
all agreed that Dr bright could never
learn about this simulation result lest
he tried to recreate it himself next
they inputted details about
scp-1594 Miss Jay's Wiz Kids Schoolhouse
the anomalous computer program capable
of teaching anyone about any subject
with a triumphant beep the computer
announced that it had rendered a
simulation of what Miss Jay's pocket
Dimension might be it was a classroom
decorated in bright colors and cutouts
of various numbers and letters on the
wall motivational portraits were
displayed including kittens grabbing
onto the rungs of a ladder with the
slogan hang in there there were
bookshelves all along the walls filled
to the brim with books at the chalkboard
a three-dimensional version of Miss Jay
herself was standing with her signature
ponytail and bright green vest a piece
of chalk in her hand the desks were all
empty but she had a chip her smile on
her face and was waiting for students to
come in and learn at any minute on the
board she had written welcome class next
they chose an entity whose inner life
was a bit more difficult to discern
whose motivations though seemingly
straightforward were perplexing
scp-049 the plank doctor forever in
pursuit of curing a pestilence that he
could not get the foundation to
understand creating lifeless zombies
whenever he attempted to treat a patient
where would this inscrutable doctor
disappear to if he only good what would
his Hideaway be the simulation rendered
a sterile laboratory environment no real
surprise given his proclivity for
medical science there were stainless
steel tables and instruments the plague
doctor stood in the fully outfitted lab
going about his work as he always did
with no one to interrupt or disturb him
on the desk in the corner set a pile of
medical texts a vase filled with
lavender flowers in fresh water and a
generous glass of Rich red wine there
was everything here that he could
possibly need what about a pocket
dimension for an entity that already had
everything it could possibly want
something so content so happy with its
everyday life that it had no need or
desire to escape
scp-999 lived as a pampered pet a sort
of foundation mascot with its every wish
for tasty treats or playtime met still
they inputted the tickle Monster's
information into the simulation to see
what it might come up with what I ran
rendered look like something out of
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory it
was a wide open field beneath a bright
blue sky filled with sunlight and fluffy
white clouds the landscape however was
not The Greenery in nature one might
expect to see but instead was made up
entirely of candy and other sweets
Boulders made of toffee a lake of melted
chocolate lollipop trees and cotton
candy bushes as far as the eye could see
nestled within the candy landscape was
an elaborate playground more of an
amusement park than the usual row of
swings and a plastic slide there was a
miniature Ferris wheel a ball pit and an
obstacle course that has CP 999 could
bounce around and navigate every simple
childlike Joy was present in this place
pure sweetness happiness and light for a
creature as good as scp-999 they would
expect nothing less next up was The
Dudley statue that moved only when out
of sight SCP-173
3. it took the researchers a moment to
understand what they were seeing when
they took a look at its Dimension at
first they thought that perhaps the
simulation had somehow crashed after all
they were looking at a pitch black
screen then they realized they were
seeing what its Dimension would look
like after all the perfect place for
SCP-173 to retreat to would be somewhere
cloaked in absolute Darkness where no
one could keep an eye on the Statue and
stop it from moving as it pleased here
it would be free to hunt and take lives
as much as it wanted keeping
unsuspecting humans in suspense as they
waited for the sound of grinding stone
to betray that the end was near the
researchers all shuddered and glanced
over their shoulders just in case since
they were already feeling unsettled they
decided to take it one step further and
see what scp-682 might create for itself
what could be home for the creature that
hates everything they were horrified to
see oblique Stony landscape where the
massive reptile was devouring everything
in sight humans plants animals none were
safe from being snapped up in its deadly
Jaws that wasn't the worst of it though
when it had finished consuming
everything
scp-682 opened its mouth and coughed all
of its victims back up miraculously
resurrected and unharmed then it began
to do it all over again ripping tearing
and clawing at all the living things
around it in an endless cycle of Despair
one researcher began to feel sick and
had to flee the room the rest pressed on
if a bit paler than they had been
moments before since the Vibes in the
room were already as bad as they could
possibly get one researcher suggested
they keep the momentum going and try out
another highly hostile anomaly the
possessive mask itself
scp-035 what sort of cursed reality
could the simulation come up with for
the militia just mask being that though
it could not move on its own seemed to
radiate an almost Unstoppable evil the
monitor showed a rendering of an
ornately decorated castle with a
medieval European sensibility gold decor
and Rich red velvet curtains dots of
black and red like blood and black goo
on everything on the walls elaborate
tapestries were hung depicting the
traditional comedy and tragedy masks
that scp-035 resembled there was a
stained glass window toward the back of
the room depicting
scp-035 with a full human body sitting
Atop A Golden Throne a crown on its head
in the very center of the room there was
scp-035 in a position matching the
stained glass window at its feet dozens
of people dressed in rags were kneeling
in supplication to their ruler the mask
was smiling of course that awful thing
would want to make itself the king of
its own private Castle forcing others to
serve its every whim time to shift gears
to something completely different
scp-2662 also known as Cthulhu despite
the creature's intimidating appearance
he was overall a relatively polite being
what would his chosen Sanctuary look
like
scp-2662's simulated pocket Dimension
was a far cry from the luxury of
scp-035s there were no riches here no
opulent displays of wealth and power it
was the opposite the room depicted
resembled a standard studio apartment
with a bed a couch a television and a
kitchenette every up-to-date game
console and some that didn't exist yet
could be seen throughout the room and
posters for various video games and
action and Sci-Fi movies Adorn the walls
there were Stacks and stacks of games
ready to be played as well as an extra
large beanbag chair positioned directly
in front of the TV screen their scp-2662
set gaming happily the room had no
windows and no visible door either no
way for strangers to intrude on his
peaceful private Leisure Time up next on
the list was scp-953 the polymorphic
humanoid but when the simulation
rendered her pocket Dimension she was
nowhere to be seen there was a beautiful
landscape like something out of a
painting of what appeared to be an
idyllic location in rural Korea there
was vibrant green grass a light blue sky
dotted with delicate wisps of clouds and
a clear trickling stream there was a man
Lying by the stream basking in the
sunlight though he didn't look like any
anomaly the research team recognized
they were checking him for The Telltale
fox ears or tail that indicated a
shape-shifted scp-953 when suddenly a
figure emerged from the water a woman
with long dark hair wearing a white
dress and with those oh so familiar ears
poking out from her scalp she stretched
her sharp claws wide and snapped her
fingers suddenly the landscape changed
the sky went dark the clouds replaced
with Fox eyes glaring down from the
heavens the stream flowed red with blood
and the grass became a carpet of gnarled
orange fur the man scrambled to his feet
in a desperate bid for escape but
scp-953 jumped on him before he could so
much take a step away from her and began
to torture him gleefully the screen went
red as if with blood the researchers
definitely needed a palette cleanser
after that nightmarish Vision so they
selected a much more wholesome entity
from the list for the next round
scp-2295 the patchwork bear that so
deeply wanted to heal the world and help
the sick and hurting its simulated
Dimension resembled an ordinary doctor's
office waiting room with chairs a
check-in desk and some toys and books
for board patients of all ages there was
one difference however everything in the
room was made from scrap Fabric and yarn
materials the bear could use to patch a
potentially infinite number of troubles
this was a place where the bear could
bring anyone in need of its help and
treat them to the best of its ability
but what about an anomaly that was not
sentient or at the very least one whose
sentience was very much Up For Debate
the team selected scp-914 for the next
simulation inputting the details of 914
or the Clockworks resulted in an image
of a small Factory with large metal
doors inside all manner of
unidentifiable Machinery worked in
tandem to rearrange and reconfigure
various items there were different
conveyor belts each marked according to
one of the Clockwork settings coarse
rough one-to-one fine and very fine
perhaps one researcher posited this
pocket Dimension was not theoretical at
all maybe this was where items went when
they disappeared into the machine's
intake Booth then again who could be
certain how exactly an item like scp-914
really worked next was
scp-073 or Kane in his Dimension the
world of Zone making he strolled through
a dense forest the vegetation thriving
all around him where it would have
ordinarily withered and died he plucked
an apple off a tree and took a bite
scp-529 Josie the half cat run through a
playroom that could only be described as
cat Heaven scratching posts Fish and
Chicken Treats balls of yarn everything
a feline friend could ever desire one
researcher wiped a tear from her eye and
when her colleagues questioned it she
just replied I really like cats okay in
a subject change another researcher
suggested trying a sort of before and
after experiment with the simulation
they would see what sort of pocket
Dimension might be generated by an
anomaly before a traumatic event and
what it might create after they settled
on scp-066 Eric's toy first they built
simulation around scp-066 as it first
behaved when it arrived at the SCP
Foundation the result produced was a
world made of colorful yarn filled with
living yarn creatures roaming around the
landscape as Eric's toy rolled among
them cheerfully then they inputted the
details of the incident that shifted the
entity's behavior when a d-class
attempted to cut off a piece of its yarn
body for study the resulting pocket
Dimension was made not of yarn but of
fleshy tendrils dripping with red that
curled and writhed like tentacles
grasping and squeezing aggressively at
anything that intruded on the space a
striking visual representation of the
change in the anomaly's mental and
emotional state next was
scp-1867 Lord Blackwood Lord blackwood's
pocket out of reality was the interior
of a grand hunting lodge with a roaring
fire in the fireplace and an impressive
if a bit Macabre bare skin rug stretched
across the floor Lord Blackwood stood in
all this brightly colored sea slug Glory
at a bar in the corner of the room next
to a glass of whiskey and a hand-carved
wooden pipe All Along The Wall were
various trophies Taxidermy of a variety
of wild beasts that the slug had hunted
over the years as well as artifacts
picked up along its travels fossils rare
books paintings and primitive weapons
there were also grainy old photographs
of Lord Blackwood with many of his
associates from over the years other
famed hunters and gentlemen explorers he
had embarked on his Expeditions
alongside
scp-4910 the grinner would dwell in a
volcanic landscape where Rock and lava
were replaced with fleshy pink gums and
teeth jutted out of every available
surface gnarly
scp-076 Abel would use his pocket
Dimension as a battle arena a grand
Coliseum of sorts filled with every
weapon imaginable where he could trap
his strongest would-be opponents and
force them into a fight to the death
scp-527 Mr fish's simulated Pocket World
resembled the city of Boston with one
notable difference every depiction of a
human being from statues to billboard
advertisements to magazine covers showed
them with fish heads atop their human
bodies there was not a human head to be
seen except at what would have
ordinarily been the seafood market there
you could find chests of ice-held fresh
human heads that were ready to be sold
though the sight of the human heads was
a bit disconcerting the research team
understood the significance of this
place it made sense that Mr Fish would
want to retreat to a world that matched
his lived experience where everyone else
looked like him there was even a hat
shop stopped with tiny little formal
hats like his very own top hat if
scp-2800 cactus man had a place between
realities that belonged exclusively to
him it would be an underground superhero
Hideout the room detected on the monitor
resembled the bat cave but with all of
the bat themed Decor replaced with
cactus-themed items instead there are
also several large sagoro cacti planted
in pots throughout the space as well as
several Cactus Man costumes and glass
cases ready to be worn
scp-294 the coffee machine would have a
secret world filled with every liquid
substance known to man and several still
undiscovered floating through the air
but somehow never mixing together any
beverage anyone could ever ask for would
be there just waiting for the right
order to come in
scp-352 Baba Yaga was next it was a
large Forest seemingly ordinary at first
glance but within its depths lurked
every fear a person could ever have
depending on what unsuspecting victim
she was able to pull into the darkness
there could be a high up Cliffside
waiting for someone afraid of heights a
giant spider awaiting an arachnophobe or
thick Inky Blackness waiting for someone
Afraid of the Dark all around the forest
floor her hair curled waiting to ensnare
her prey
scp-662 more specifically
scp-662-1 Mr Deeds quite possibly
already occupied a pocket Dimension when
his Bell was not in use though they had
no way to know for certain the
simulation predicted that his break room
of sorts might look like this a blue
room with two shelves filled with
cleaning tools a brown couch and a
little bed in the corner where the
Butler could sleep during his time off
scp-169 Leviathan would disappear into
an aquatic pocket Dimension a place
large enough for it to swim comfortably
possibly forever in the peaceful
infinite ocean then the research staff
decided to input
scp-096 and see what the Shy Guy's
pocket Dimension might look like unlike
the old man this anomaly was not
aggressive all the time and it seemed to
take no pleasure in hunting instead it
acted in a kind of Twisted self-defense
attacking anything that saw its face and
set it off on a spree of violence that
ended in death
scp-096's potential pocket Dimension was
a dark dismal Labyrinth like something
out of the Greek myth of the Minotaur
Stone corridors Twisted this way and
that leading any potential Intruders
down dead ends and away from the center
were
scp-096 hid from sight in the center
there was light and Life trees grass a
small pond and a nest filled with blind
birds chirping and singing to scp-096 as
it sat in complete obscurity away from
prying eyes now go check out scp-001
when daybreaks
scp-106 and scp-096 versus
scp-106 for more crazy what-ifs
involving a certain slimy old man